non-minimalists
so let's let's go back to some of those
very early days and
i want to even start before you started
the minimalist and
you know you're at that lonely lunch
table senior year high school trying to
figure out what you want to do with your
life decide to go down this this
corporate path
and and set your your eyes on making
your first fifty thousand dollars
yeah um you know was the corporate
path the only path that you guys saw at
that point in your life and
i'm also curious what success looked
like for you as
young fresh green 18 year old man for me
like i grew up with my dad owning his
own business painting and hanging
wallpaper
and he got by but it was just like he
was just barely getting by
and i remember when i graduated hi and i
worked i worked for him
uh during high school during the summers
but when i graduated like my plan was to
work for him
and then eventually take over the
business
but then i like started to realize at
like 18 19 years old
i'm like wait a minute like i'm putting
in like 40
50 hours a week and hardly
getting by myself uh
i don't want to take this business over
and your dad was always having money
problems
always while he owned the bill i
remember one day when he was paying his
taxes
he wrote a letter to put in his taxes
he's like hey i'm sorry that my taxes
are short i had to feed my family and
like just send in a short check
holy cow i know man and it's the
government never got back to him either
like i don't know if they let it slide
or what but
that's amazing that he wrote them a
letter most people just don't pay
he's like here's what i here's what i
have like sorry i defeat my family
but you know when when i graduated high
school college wasn't an option
um being raised as one of jehovah's
witnesses they do not encourage college
the end of the world's going to be here
so why would you go to college
that's a good point think about how how
dangerous that mindset is like growing
up as a kid
you were basically told like ah don't
worry about it go into debt
forget about college because you know
we're all
going to see the end of the world within
the next 10 years i mean there's a lot
of uh
i mean this is totally an aside but
there are a lot of cases like in the
late 80s or maybe early 80s only
we'll just say the 80s yeah where maybe
it's the middle that organization
specifically had this huge wave of
um bankruptcies in their organization
because that's exactly the i mean they
went out and took out loans
more than what they could afford
thinking that well i'm not going to pay
back this loan i'll just you know go
ahead
and do this and jesus will come and save
everything and fix everything
but anyway so so college was not an
option um i certainly couldn't afford it
i never saved ford i had no idea
um i had no idea how how to even
approach
going to college i remember like when i
when i actually did go to college i
started when i was 25 years old
and i was talking to my boss and uh she
this was in the corporate world because
the corporation paid for 100 of it
so i was like well i might as well go to
school if they're gonna pay for it and i
went to my boss and i'm like hey can you
help me
figure out how to go to college and the
look on her face was like
she's like did no one ever sit you down
like when you graduated high school and
show you like how to apply
i'm like no like i got out of high
school i started working for my dad
and realized you know two years into it
this sucks uh
i remember telling my dad i'm like dad
you work
this much some days he come in dude and
he's got this
stress dot above his it's like right
between his eyes
and if you see that dot you just don't
talk to him because he's so stressed out
does it like blotchy red skin kind of
thing yeah and it's only this one spot
it's really weird right between his eyes
but but my point is i remember like
seeing that dot one day and i'm like dad
you make x amount of dollars and you
work x amount of hours a week
this doesn't make sense to me like
there's got to be something else out
there
that we can do or that i can do and you
know eventually
i was talking to josh about what he was
doing and i remember him telling me
um he was yeah he's like i'm selling
cell phones i'm like sweet i'm like
how much money do you make selling cell
phones he's like i don't know i think
this
this this month i made like 6 500 bucks
7 000 bucks this is back in 2001.
and he was in ohio yeah and he was and
he's you know 20 years old
21 and i'm like i thought he was lying
i'm like dude no way
i blew it off for months and months um
maybe even a year or so i just remember
uh i was in josh's wedding and we got to
you know we were talking more and more
about um
me doing something different i hated
what i was doing at the time and finally
i was like all right dude
i'll try it out and yeah like that first
month i
made like actually that's not true
remember the first couple months it was
like the slow
yeah you were doing about you were you
thinking about firing there
no no no no no no no the entire company
was just slow yeah it was just it was
just a really weird time
but that first commission check i got um
it was a couple months later
and it was like 4 500 bucks and the
first thing i did is i went and bought a
new truck
i was like sweet man i can i can afford
a down payment
yeah to get another payment yeah yeah
yeah but uh no it was it was an
interesting uh
it was an interesting uh start to to a
new career i mean i was really excited
and
you know for all intents and purposes
man i loved it for the first you know
couple few years
but you know it gets it wears on you
after a while
what was the question again i i tried to
drop out of high school
and um that's right uh
my my the counselor you know the the
high school counselor he you basically
go to him and talked about why you want
to drop out
and part of the reason was like all the
friends in my my neighborhood had
already dropped out
um at least most of them and it was my
senior year and i was just like so done
and i wanted i knew i wanted to do
something in business
but but i also knew that that i
i wasn't going to college route and i'm
like this high school thing is
it doesn't make any sense i'm i was
already like 17 at the time and i wanted
to just move on
and he he got to the point where he he
wouldn't
let me drop out of high school
um but i got he was able to convince me
that basically
he could stack my whole schedule with a
bunch of study halls
and i'd take two or three classes to
graduate and he let me take off the
entire second semester of of
my senior year of high school because
otherwise he knew i was done but i knew
i wasn't going to go to college and so i
went out and got
full-time job sales job and that's when
i started climbing the corporate ladder
and it was weird i just said yes to this
thing because of
of money that was the primary driver we
all need to make money and i said well
here's the best opportunity to make
money
but i didn't really know what i was
going to do with the money i thought i
was so
unhappy growing up because we didn't
have any money really poor food stamps
government assistance
and and money would obviously solve all
of my problems if i could just have
enough money then then i would be happy
and then of course
i by age 19 i was making more money than
i ever saw my parents
make when i was growing up you know my
dad wasn't around it was just my mom
raising me and so
i had debt for the first time it's not
like i was making great money
i i was more broke than i was a year
prior because
i had these credit cards that showed up
in the mail and then i
started renting out a nicer apartment
and realized like
i was saying yes to everything that
looked
appetizing to my life right it was it
was appealing at the time
and so i in a weird way
ended up sitting in the passenger seat
of my own life
where because i had said yes all these
other things like all of a sudden i
wasn't in control anymore
like someone else was driving it was the
credit cards
the job that i started work i was
working 80 hours a week
and i was really good at it too and that
was another problem you get all these
accolades and you win these presidents
club awards and they send you off on
trips to hawaii or london or wherever
and and then they give you these
promotions and you start climbing this
corporate ladder and you get to this
point where
it gets scary to look down so you just
keep climbing up
and i was the youngest director in my
company's history by age of 27.
140 year old telecom company and
i got really close to the guys i aspired
to be like i had a whole plan in place i
was going to be
a vice president by age 32
which is really young now i was gonna be
senior vice president by age 35 a
c-level executive by age 40. like that
was my plan as i
as i was climbing but it all started
when i was 18 and decided i'm going to
go this path it wasn't a deliberate path
it was just a
i'll say yes to this i guess and i think
that's okay especially when you're young
to say yes to a bunch of
things early on but keep questioning
those things
and that's where i ran astray i wasn't
questioning any of it well this is the
path i'm supposed to take i've already
gotten this far
and so i'll keep climbing and but as i
got closer to those guys i really
aspired to be like like i really want to
be the cfo one day our co
is what i really wanted to be and but as
i got closer to some of these guys
man they were miserable heart attacks
and third
divorces and and huge money problems
even though they were making
seven figures some of them uh or really
close to it
and then i realized that well if i
follow that same path i'm gonna end up
in the same place i think we all tell
ourselves like well
i'll be different but why if you if you
follow the same recipe you're going to
bake the same cake as someone else
and so that's kind of where where where
i ended up in
this place of not true discontent but of
a place of of dissatisfaction
um and it lacked anything
meaningful to me and so of course i
tried to pacify myself with
with pleasure basically it sounds like
minimalism came at
the perfect time for you because given
the choice at 18 years old where it's
like hey
do you want all this money right or do
you want minimalism
right like i don't think you would have
chosen minimalism at that point in your
life
um but you you'd gone through a lot of
uh experience and you saw for yourself
what worked and what didn't work
was it that you you knew that you were
dis discontent or was it minimalism that
helped pull you out of that and realize
that this wasn't for you
well there's nothing wrong with money
first off like i think money can be
great
it allows you to accomplish a lot if you
use it deliberately the problem that i
had
throughout my 20s is yeah i grew up poor
and i thought the reason we were
discontented is we didn't have money
the reason we were actually discontented
is we made repeated bad decisions with
the little money that we did have
and i just carried those decisions
forward into my 20s
had i made good decisions with that
money there was a point in my career i
was making a couple hundred thousand
dollars a year
in in dayton ohio uh which we're out in
los angeles now i don't can't even
imagine what that would be
like like here you you it's
orders of magnitude different but but
the point being is if i would have made
better decisions with that money then
i think i still could have led a
meaningful life you can be a rich person
and
live a meaningful life you can be a poor
person and live a meaningful life
i've seen both sides of of the spectrum
minimalism showed up at a time for me
where
it felt like i got into those two car
crashes you know my
my marriage ended my mother died both in
the same month
and and and you know it feels like you
get
just t-boned at a light and then someone
else rams into you right after that
but then there's almost like this after
the accident someone ran
over my foot because i realized like no
i wasn't very contented with
with what i was doing for my corporate
career
and it's not that i hated it but it was
comfortable it was a six out of ten
and that was actually part of the
problem is like it it got in the way of
everything meaningful in my life my
health my relationships i wasn't writing
like i wanted to write i wasn't creating
how i wanted to create
i certainly wasn't contributing in a
meaningful way but
i was making a good income i had a nice
house i had
several lexuses and i realized like
alexis or lexa yeah that's a good
question
i don't know shawn's not here to look it
up for us um
but uh yeah and so you get you get to
this point where you are
are comfortable and you're afraid to
lose that comfort
and minimalism was a way for me to
realize that that comfort was a bit of a
facade
and comfort was getting in the way of
what i considered to be
meaningful
you